what's up guys Ryan right over here so
today I'm gonna check out a video from
honest trailers called Hulk honest
trailers remember that movie the one
that no one liked anyway that's the
Angley version the one with Eric Bana I
haven't seen this movie in years but I'm
sure I'll get a lot of the insults
you love Mark Ruffalo you tolerated
Edward Norton but admitted you forgot
about Eric Bana until I said his name
just now get ready for the most
forgettable movie about a giant
rage-filled monster ever made in Oh
before Hulk was an Avenger before he was
even incredible traveled back to a time
when Kevin Feige could still gov a
superhero movie as director Angley
presents a two-hour long brooding think
piece about a green guy who smashes
things stop staring at that bush and hit
something
beep Bruce better you wouldn't like it
when he's angry or calm
ah Harvey
so hon he is a monotone unlikable
scientist we're doing the basic science
for everyone working with his
ex-girlfriend Betty a monotone unlikable
scientist you're head of the base I
thought you're in charge and one of the
dullest superhero movies ever made that
covers up its total lack of action with
super wacky scene transitions
Wow it's just like reading a comic book
a terrible with his true nature
unleashed then a freak accident turns
him into a man who looks like he's
struggling to hold in a fart until he
finally lets it go and becomes the hero
the 2003 CGI clearly wasn't ready for
resulting in a Hulk that's one part
PlayStation cutscene one part frat guy
and two parts Shrek Hulk his love
Hulk is all anyone wants you to see is
the Hulk go up against someone of equal
or greater spring well too bad because
this time the Green Giant is going
toe-to-toe with lightweight non threats
like this douche the US military's for
might of a few tanks and helicopters oh
dogs hot dogs you saved my life they're
from a mutant french poodle and Bruce
banners own father who's either an
unpredictable mad scientist or just
McNulty wandering onto the set and being
himself for a few hours
resulting in an impossible to see climax
that takes place at night underwater
against a cloud dad thing Thor the dark
world is looking pretty good right now
huh starring Eric banana Betsy Ross Sam
Elliott's mustache loss Nick Nolte's mug
shot
and don't make him angry Salk
Hulk introspect be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers cheery
we are unhone sufferin succotash I'm a
simple man i CBS I press like Michael
Bay is a menace the hammer of Justice is
unisex I'm a lick lick and lick a
lollipop we're yeah that movie wasn't
egregious I went on opening night so
Jack to watch it and I I fell asleep but
the second time I watched it you know
there are things about the film that I
actually sort of appreciate I personally
don't find Eric mana as boring as a lot
of people did I kind of did like how
Angley sort of edited it and shot it
kind of trying to make it look like a
comic book it's sometimes a little too
in you're actually a lot of times a
little too in-your-face but for the most
part I appreciate a lot of its intent I
don't love the movie I still fall asleep
almost every time I check it out
but there are things about it that I do
enjoy there things about it that are not
so bad but I can see why no one likes it
anyway guys thanks for timing that was
out if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
like I keep saying Tyrone Magnus 1
billion subscribers Ryan Wright product
placement get a certain amount of
followers on Instagram and Twitter you
can do product placement meaning I don't
have to work as much to make a lot of
money